[Music]
i want to bring ganeshan i mean i've
read that you've mentioned scientists
using a metaphor of scissors cutting out
genetic sequences and that's something
you would disagree with so there are
presumably metaphors that become
unhelpful or we get stuck in a way of
thinking is that something you'd argue
i mean
yes absolutely i mean
metaphors are
are sort of time limited um
methods basically for getting a concept
across
so you know when talking about genome
editing of dna
you can use metaphors such as scissors
cutting paper
just to get across the concept of you
know
top tier level stuff but it doesn't
actually work like that
so you know on one hand the metaphor
helps get the concept across but on the
other hand one might say it distracts
from the scientific truth of what's
happening because that isn't what is
actually happening there
alluding back to what um hillary and
peter were just discussing the
scientific theories
uh make predictions
right that's actually
the the the heart of of science that you
can make a prediction based on what you
understand if you've understood it right
and then you can go ahead and test that
and it's through these iterative you
know predictions and testings of
reality or as close to reality as we can
get to it obviously
um
that we make progress
and you know to to
i found myself really torn listening to
both peter and hillary there because on
one hand i'm absolutely i you know my
heart side with peter and i think yeah
we are we are optimist scientists you
know we
dedicate our entire lives to
understanding the the finer grain
movements of a single molecule in a
particular organism at a particular
point in time
you know that's that's no mean feat as
it were
but equally i feel like
you know there's that the the thing that
i alluded to even in my opening comments
sort of um resonated with what hillary
said about you know is that is there any
hope for an organism such as
um us to actually be able to externalize
ourselves sufficiently to be able to
turn back and observe ourselves
and i understand that sort of reticence
or that you know maybe pessimism as
peter might put it but equally it does
have to be said we've we've done
remarkably well so far
you know so
whilst whilst maybe the point stands
we're doing an alright job and maybe the
future looks relatively bright
i would say yes rupa i want to bring you
in because you've argued that the whole
notion that nature is mechanical and
working in accordance with mathematics
is itself um a fundamental assumption
and presumably then a metaphor would you
argue that that therefore can this be
tested and refuted um is it not even a
scientific theory in your view
well i think the machine theory of
nature is clearly a metaphor i can't
think of an experiment you could do that
would definitively refute it because you
can see
as hillary said you can look at nature
in a mechanical way through that lens
you like the hearts like a pump the
brain could be compared to a computer to
some degree
but so these are all inadequate uh
metaphors um
i think though that you see
i disagree with peter in this idea that
mathematics is somehow truer um you
don't use maths in most of uh science i
mean the triumphs of molecular biology
for example have very little to do with
mathematics there's a bit of mathematics
and genetics
but you know when people are doing
mutants and and with arabidopsis or
cenorabditos and these mutational
studies they're not primarily
mathematical at all i've been wading
through dozens of these papers in the
last few weeks and there's no mass in
any of them
if you're doing the taxonomy of orchids
you look at orchid flies you go to the
herbarium queue you look at press
specimens of orchids you don't use
equations
and if you then assume well ultimately
somehow later down the line with
inconceivably huge computers we could
actually figure it all out with
computers and that's nothing but
promissory materialism or promissory
mathematics
and when we come to what mathematical
physicists themselves do
we find that they spin webs of what i
would regard as fantasy for example the
superstring theory which has predicts
the existence of 10 to the 500 universes
is one of the underlying theoretical
tissues of assumption underneath under
the multiverse theory
many many physicists based on this
mathematics believe that there are
countless unobserved actual universes
the multiverse and
this to my mind is nothing but fantasy
based on mathematics so i don't think
mathematics has any superior claim it's
just another set of metaphors and that
particular set of metaphors
lead to
untestable predictions that seem to be
very close to fantasy um peter would you
like to come in on this notion that
mathematical physicists are fantasists
uh possibly respond on that yes but
ultimately they they they test their
ideas against
um observation i was going to say
reality but that would be
circus circular they tested against
observation if it turns out that there
are
10 to the 500 universes or an infinite
number of universes out there then that
would be a great triumph for the theory
and rupert can't just lie back and just
miss it as a simple fantasy it might be
true and we've got no way at the moment
of predicting whether it is true or not
but it's worth thinking about especially
if it has other implications which can
be tested for it but for example
the same theory might predict the the
charge of an electron in which case we
can go out and measure the charge in the
electron and see whether we get an
agreement with observation i mean
fantasy is fantastic
but it is it should always be granted in
observation
can
he did make the point that um there are
theories that are not mathematical i
need i did make that point in my open
discussion when referring to something
like natural natural selection and so on
so yes there are these two great grand
classes
of
scientific explanation which i would
call the mathematical and the literary
yes thank you can i hear you you've
argued in the past um that you know the
realest notion that our scientific
metaphors describe reality is in fact
damaging to science i mean would you
like to
um explain that a little more and maybe
respond to peter as well
gosh were there a lot of rather big
and difficult topics going on on here
i think
this issue about mathematics is it is
certainly a central one to address and
in a way i applaud peter for for taking
the sort of um
pushing as it were on the scientific
ontology to the point of having
identified that all of the other things
that people have proposed as being the
ultimate bits of the universe which
might be physical objects or things or
particles or whatever doesn't really
stand up when you
when you explore it and has sort of
retreated as it were to a position of
saying the world just is mathematics and
um
i i think uh
uh
i think i understand why he's why he's
made that move
um because none of the other ones are
available but i i don't think that we
should buy that one either and instead
we should um conclude that uh
uh
so along the lines of what rupert was
saying that mathematics is itself a way
of holding the world but i think there
is a further puzzle for
those of us who hold a sort of model
theoretic account what's going on here
which is to explain why it is that
magmatic works quite so well
i mean you know the pythagoras theorem
does predict the length of the
hypotenuse and how does it do that if it
hasn't uncovered something essential
about the character of the world
um
now
i do have a sort of answer for that and
now it's not a good good time to develop
it but i would say it's something to do
with the structure of uh thought it's
something that mathematics operates on
the basis the world is made of bits uh
that's what numbers are but you assume
there is a one there is a two there are
bits and when you apply that principle
that the world is divided into bits you
can generate a logic of how those bits
function
in fact i suppose the world is not made
of bits in that way it's our thought
that imposes the bits on the world and
mathematics is part of that and uh
that's why in the end uh we find uh it
can be so powerful in certain
certain situations so the yes i mean the
mathematics question this is the kind of
third aspect of our debate and
we may as well go into it now i think
because it's as you say hillary it's an
enormous subject um and this kind of
ganesh i wanted to ask you about this
because you use vast quantities of data
um presumably is there a point at which
things might become
incommunicable without metaphors so you
almost need a way to
convey these and is there a possibility
that then things are inevitably
simplified when they go into language
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you